gang the boys are on the road with that
stay trashy tour coming to a town near
you grab the squad come out and see us
little stand-up comedy plus we played a
little ayg with the crowd it's a good
good time yeah gang uh June 14th we're
gonna be at hilarities in Cleveland June
15th we're going to be at the Funny Bone
in Columbus then obviously we have New
Jersey the Vogel theater the second show
added for that those tickets are going
get them before they're gone uh we'll be
adding more shows get your tickets are
you garbage.com love you yeah welcome so
another exciting edition of are you
garbage
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage that little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find that if they grow up to be
classy after just a big old piece of
trash I'm your host Dave Foley coming at
you on a beautiful day we're out back
here at hoodies in the new edition baby
she's down at the track trying to find a
trainer that'll play ball okay trying to
roll some money over my co-host is
coming at you from across the table it's
what we call a family episode around
here just the boys just the bozos just
the homies it's a nice tight little
circle we like to do every once in a
while here my co-host the king of the
flatbreads give it up for KJ Kevin James
Ryan loves a flatbread who don't love a
good FB flatbread is an entree blew my
mind the first time I seen that was I
the first guy to do that 100 leopard as
an entree it's a pizza never what do you
mean never nobody in the following
orders flatbreads by the way first of
all what that's a rip-off you love them
and you they're great they're good and I
don't care I don't have to share with
you [__] mean mugging me from across
the table [__] drooling looking at me
well that was a flatbread what up gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate if you subscribe over
there on iTunes full video available on
YouTube as you know those numbers are
cooking and obviously the greatest gosh
darn website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage gang
check it the [__] out we're coming up on
almost 10 000 patrons baby sir 10 000
patrons shout out to the homies and also
the second greatest episode of all time
www.ru garbage.com check that out you
get all your tickets for the shows sure
you get your merch you got your t-shirts
and your Zippo styled lighters in
parentheses and more stuff coming more
stuff coming yeah see what else we can
get off brand
see when I was North Korea shipping
these days you know what I'm saying sure
oh also boom hit him with the Bernie
there you go look at that T-Bone hit me
look at that that's a top seller right
there yes it is it does very well does
all right we love it sold nine of them
gonna be a banner year that's old eight
and this one I paid full price by the
way trying to juice the numbers a little
bit gang having a nice quick shout out
to our producer extraordinaire the magic
man makes us all look good works the
ones the twos the threes and the fours
he crosses the t's and he dots the eyes
his hair is long and his jeans are tight
give it up for T-Bone mcgruffins it's
that Toby McMullen over there gang hey
what up boys
is there a more Aunt entree than the
flatbread that's up there with like
Fresca to me I'm not gonna sit here and
take this flatbread
you're taking it the wrong way
for me yeah he called me an ant I'll let
the slander go by you but don't act like
you almost didn't finish my flatbread
wherever the [__] we just went see
that's what I'm talking about you got it
all wrong baby relax he's got it right
now yeah two are throwing shade at one
of the greatest things on a menu ever I
think it's fantastic I I'm complimenting
you that I have never been around
anybody in my entire life I'm 47 years
old nobody I know nobody innovated on
such a level nobody you act like I ask
if they don't have them like hey can you
whip me up a flat bread back there I
mean if they're on the menu and I know
they ain't got chicken tendies I'm going
for FB nobody I know ever in my life and
I'm being dead honest nobody in my life
has ever [__] with a flatbread I was
always curious about it and I really
understood what it was I know it's like
a pizza but there's kind of holes in the
bottom it's a pizza you're stuck beating
around the bush it's an oval Pizza okay
right okay all right and bread's a
little different yes and it's on like a
Pub menu I think I think it's I I think
it's Innovative and I think it's great
and it's always it's it's like it's like
the the best show you're not watching I
I I I I I never think of it when it
comes to ordering and you go I'll notice
of food
yeah characters welcome shout out to USA
their program their original program was
all right and Suits was fantastic too
great show great show man I had hots for
her before she went so we can join the
Redcoats so is the one out in the
Hamptons the veterinarian that solved
crimes or whatever it was you know what
I'm talking about
my monk was good monkey it was great I
can't remember what it was called kitty
cat Mysteries no
but I'll tell you what you give me 1500
words I'll produce it tomorrow tell you
that right now I got a little Starlet at
home I'm gonna be reading for the lead
right there
um never thought to get a flatbread and
every time you get well obviously I
don't get them now but when you go I'm
like oh [__] that's a good idea it's
good it's good the idea around it and
this is flawed logic in my head usually
not done well we can agree on that yeah
they're not you they're usually not
great no but it's a hit the scene hard
everybody went nuts for him then he got
a lot of [__] bozos out there trying
to make him and they suck I gotta be
honest I only I think I might have
ordered about four in the past two years
in my head you have them every day
that's crazy every time we're somewhere
I get like a chicken salad or something
like that this guy goes give me a
[__] flat bread and they come over
with a [__] Boomer
he's mad he got mad at me where were we
were in Dania Beach Florida at the
Improv in Dania Beach so mad at me dude
they make a flatbread pizza that'll blow
your compression socks off holy [__] it
was legit upset because I was like yeah
I wasn't that good or what I got it we
got it from next door he's like ah I
wasn't that good don't you [__] say
that that thing looks delicious oh it's
delicious mean I look over he's chewing
on his knuckles
you talk about that sweet little angel
like that uh I don't get them honestly
ever I kind of get them on the road I
think because a lot of times we're
rolling the dice wherever we are it's a
switch up at uh
they're only offered at like bars and
pubs you know what I mean like places
that don't have fantastic menus so it's
like if I don't want to get the in my
head it's a little lighter in my head
it's like two and a half slices of pizza
if I finish it that's a half a pizza
that's a half a large pizza no I don't
think I don't think so
you've seen these things right it looks
like there's been four so you can't it
looks like it looks like the thing you
put the paints on when you're painting
yeah that's half the size of a regular
pizza and then it's on that so which is
even smaller and I didn't finish the one
in Dania Beach always served on like a
cutting board or something like that
yeah you can't fit half a pizza on a
half a large pizza on a cutting board I
have the technical difference between a
flat bread and a pizza excellent bread
there's no
it's called flat bread what are we doing
here yeastless bread
yeah yeah yeah that's all you got pizza
it's bad Pizza who invented it it's got
to be like Chinese
Google's just a picture of me
find out you're behind it all along high
on my own Supply uh it has to be like a
Applebee's or Chili's or something like
that well it was Persian soldiers in 500
BC so you're pretty close really I heard
they did own a lot of Applebee's though
hey we're the head five franchisees
[Laughter]
that was that was a war technology the
flatbread yeah probably just bread and
then whatever they got on it
you got you got [__] mozzarella and
pepperoni no that's 10A okay what do you
think they were putting on it they're
probably just doing like non-stuff yeah
ah it's good a non-pizza that'd be all
right
okay hold on
we gotta go check him because that's the
smartest thing you've ever said really
that's a non garlic non-beatza a garlic
naan pizza with chicken marsala on top
boom let's go that's just what I do when
I go to the Indian joint of course what
are we talking about
I'll even get crazy and throw rice on
there oh yeah and also they got three
dollar Lagunitas ipas I walk out of
their cross side
shout out to the boys
happy hour all day long in my
neighborhood daddy
um that's good stuff in my head like I
said it's lighter than a burger it's not
it's bad it's this fat guy logic here
and I'm not saying it but like if I'm
having one before we go perform listen
our Burger sits in my I'm telling you
why I got them I'm telling you I have no
ill will in this I know I'm just respect
the move I'm explaining it doesn't sit
in my stomach as per a burger and fries
and maybe potato skins one sure you know
what I mean it's just I'm a little more
it's like it's like it's the same
mentality getting a quesadilla it's not
that much healthier for you than 10
tacos but in my head it's a little
lighter sure that's what I do that's why
I do it shout out to this brought to you
by kipi's flatbreads I like it I wanted
to ask you this what's that uh
two things one uh-huh I heard her the
other day and I haven't heard her in
years are you guys too young to remember
DJ Delilah
Hey There Delilah no Hey There Delilah
do you know what I'm talking about
what's it like in New York DJ Delilah no
she does like the the call-in show she's
through the call-in show the Heartbreak
show call in hey my husband left me in
20 years can you play what year was this
on do you think she's on the radio now I
mean she does like Sirius or something
like I got serious money all right you
guys have no idea what I'm talking about
Toby got it
uh okay uh I'm coming I had a hectic
morning here uh as you know
this cleaning lady's got me jammed up as
you know we assumed you were there was a
moment where you thought I was doing
drugs drugs why because you had a lot of
H Foley 2006 Behavior I gotta go meet
someone then you get here you're like no
I had to wait for someone then you're
like oh to Uber did this the Uber did
that they ran through a couple red
lights this and that I do see what
you're saying this was out of my [__]
playbook in oh six baby
about drugs
because that's what you do man if I was
doing drugs I don't know I don't lie
about my alcoholism I let that ride it's
on the set baby I built a life around it
if I was if I started doing drugs I
wouldn't hide it well you'd be freaking
out oh yeah first of all we wouldn't be
able to do the show I would be losing my
mind I don't even take Advil hiding
doing the job I'm a control freak hiding
doing the drugs I like to will away my
headaches I've seen what you do in a
flight delay I can't imagine a couple of
hits of weed oh yeah oh that's another
thing too you you were saying that
um the other day at the airport but I've
never really you pulled an audible and
just went through the one the the one
day yes but your your anxiety is usually
not that bad oh no I felt like I was
doing a bank job
it's crazy what you're you're shocked
that I jumped ahead because we weren't
sit yeah you jump like seven zones I did
Kibby got us jammed up on a United
flight going somewhere yeah my fault we
were in the back like dirt balls uh and
then you just [__] you just they
called for veterans and you were just
locked up with my limp you were right
through the line dude I was acting like
I was blind just feeling them feeling
the flight attendants by the way you're
very beautiful hey you're a beautiful
man
uh yeah and then when we talked
afterwards you said yeah your anxiety
really got you what's your what's your
flight anxiety Something's Gonna Go Down
wouldn't you want to be with the big dog
I don't understand
let's pop this bubble of you being
useful in any situation ever you can't
tie your shoes you can't get in and out
I'm not talking about tying my shoes
talking about mixing it up talking about
taking guys down
I have to get up so you can get up I
have to Handy your luggage I have to put
it in the overhead bin what are you
gonna do annoy them to death
hey buddy what are you doing with Dad
where do you go where are you guys from
originally you guys got super fresh out
there when do you have meatballs for the
first time just saying the Pledge of
Allegiance
uh I'll turn them no that was there was
no seats no that time was something else
there was no seats
we were jammed up you guys were eating
yeah and we were sitting there like
bozos and I was just like oh [__] it I
want to go try to just [__] get on
yeah okay no that was that but we were
somewhere I get real [__] frantic
getting on planes I have a bad anxiety I
I pay to get on the flight ahead of time
so I can sit there and just chill I'm
worried about having to check my bag of
where it just you just I don't I just
want to get in put my bag work along sit
down put my headphones in and listen to
a pod all right that's what I like doing
that's taken care of now what's going on
with the drugs
what are you on I'm on nothing uppers
downers side lasers left rights they're
[__] going popping stop lights no
nothing I just [__]
and for the listener we've mentioned it
before the cleaning like we got me and
my wife got a cleaning lady and she
[__] airs me out on Instagram like a
[__] jerk off just she's doing like
the green yucky faces in my bathroom and
stuff like what the [__] and she's still
doing it and I'm now I'm like I spent
all morning cleaning the apartment for
this broad thing how do you grow a set
of balls and tell her hey lady knock it
the [__] off cause I'm a [__] Jesus
what do you mean she's not like tagging
me ah Kevin right now
I don't know what to miss if you're
listening please do that
girl to clean a [__]
a [__] it sucks it was [__] it's
been killing me what'd she get you for
first 130.
it's not that bad there's a lot of dog
hair in there I think a lot and the
worst part is she's the only cleaning
lady in New York right well my wife and
Washington hides no less my wife crazy
dude [__] when I live [__] when I lived
with when I live with my nine and a half
million people one cleaning lady yeah
busy girl
she was she was late today
she got nine million other houses to
clean showed up with a coffee just like
Santa Claus dude yeah
yeah should get to your fat ass when she
gets to you now sit in your filth and
wait for me taking losses over here dude
what she might as well be on drugs
what'd she look like by the way uh white
chick if that's what you're asking no
well I mean what do you want I mean
she's five five big set of cans what do
you want for me yeah I was looking for
something sexy not a profile uh yeah not
sexy it's not like the videos I watch
getting stuck in everything I think I
put my wedding ring down the garbage
disposal uh
yeah it just [__] jams me up it's
frustrating because then you gotta tell
a line of how filthy your house not that
my place is filthy but uh you know we
need a cleaning lady
uh you're telling the line of like what
filth you want to present to some it's
like you have company coming over
you know what I mean yeah you gotta
clean up you gotta you gotta show like
you're not living like Annie miles you
know I got too much stuff in the
apartment the stuff's everywhere man
there's stuff does she go behind the
couch and get the little dust bunnies
and all that stuff and fingernails nah I
don't think so oh really that's where I
put them oh me too yeah yeah it's like
The Lovely Bones I get yelled at heavy
for it oh yeah
I'm always stashing a fingernail I try
I've got I've gotten Toby is disgusted
by this I've gotten a bajillion times
better a bajillion your house is without
a doubt the grossest apartment you have
an outside trash can in your living room
that's not true that's not true it's not
not true I have a I have a little Trash
Can which was an incredible addition
everyone should do no trash can in the
living room it's a small guy it's a
little stepper it's great no you have
the metal one like Oscar the Grouch
that's simply human with the Captain
American Shield I look at that
somebody else's house number spray
painter no it's like a little one like
you'd have in the bathroom
that's no you can't do it's not a it's
not a Lobby it's not a waiting room I
mean there's a bike in there it might as
well be there's an old Oldsmobile
man you ever have one of your boys with
a motorcycle in the apartment yikes one
dirt bike in the living room no like a
you know like a walk-up apartment not
like a like a high-rise or anything like
that like in The Burbs
apartment would be even worse than that
like one step you can get a you can get
a dirt bike at one step one you know one
flight of stairs yeah like Sean Hunter's
dad you never had is that a friend of
yours I know Sean yeah we grew up with
them did you really yeah wait how'd you
guys both know them he lived with me and
then he lived with shut up
Sean Hunter's a good name that'd be a
kid who would have a dirt bike yeah you
know it was a good kid grew up on the
wrong side of the tracks but we
straightened him out all right
anywho
in your 20s you never had a buddy who
rode dirt bikes I didn't know Sam
Kinison
yeah we had dirt bikes you kept him in
the shed of the garage or something I
knew a couple dudes that had dirt bikes
in their living room that's where they
kept it my boy alex the one you met we I
mean you've met a bunch but the one we
saw in Austin he might have there was a
he used to live off Gerard Ave when he
started getting into he looked down
there yeah I think for a while there was
a motorcycle he lived on the front like
first floor apartment I think there was
a motorcycle in there now I think about
it yeah [__] wake up next to the oil
I'm on the floor the oil's tripping in a
pan I think it was sweet though if they
were ever in a pinch you can get out of
there quick right through the windshield
right at the front window look I love
how you turn into [__] Schwarzenegger
when [__] hits the fan
y'all just ran through the bay window
you stick with me kid he'll be looking
for the keys
how do you start thinking just get it
started and I'll be good get the helmet
on backwards
um this episode is brought to you by
better help better help gang when you're
constantly caring for other people you
know you forget about yourself that's
right baldy you forget about yourself
and that's the most important person to
you I know and I got news for you I
reached out
uh so I hear yeah uh-huh big green fans
doing a better help shout out to better
help man it's all right I'll tell you
that you do it from the privacy of your
own home you talk to somebody you could
do it over text bounce a couple of
things off somebody I'm bouncing bits
with my guy Corey
hey you ever heard anybody do anything
about Donuts guys it's fantastic can you
tighten this up for me uh I've always
said I've been a big proponent of talk
therapy uh you can use it uh you know
every week if you want or something
we're all crazy get through part-time
Hard Times your life breakups job
promotion anything you need uh family
[__] it'll they can help you take care
of it better help is completely online
you can do therapy when and where works
for you whether that's under the covers
in bed or in between call in the car
between appointments getting started is
easy that's what's great about better
help you're just in the pool then you
figure it out finding the finding a
therapist can be very daunting you put
it off I'll do it next week better help
just get you in the pool and then you
figure it out from there if you're
jammed up take that first step uh find
more balance with betterhealth visit
betterhealth.com garbage today to get 10
off your first month that's better
health help help.com garbage
betterhelp.com garbage do it okay let's
talk about Adam and Eve
let's talk about boner alert and aisle
four all right it's a fan favorite
gang everybody's got a spice up in the
bedroom a little bit even if it's spicy
take it up and I don't care if you're
using cinnamon cumin whatever you got if
you're installing a sex swing or you're
just trying out some new lubies uh-huh
you know what I mean it's got a little
freaky yeah world's coming to an end
baby let's get weird uh yeah right now
you can get up to 50 off just about I
mean God damn they really want you to
put your wiener in something over here
at Adam and Eve and I respect if you
don't have a sex swing you're throwing
money away a half-price sex swing what
do we do get one for the neighbor
uh if you're still living in your mom's
basement don't worry Adam and Eve has
discreet packaging
doesn't come from boners.net uh so
she'll never mom will never never know
you're stocking up but she's got to go
to work sometime get the freak on
downstairs in the man cave yeah she
might have some questions when she comes
down to make your bed and you got a
[__] sex swing hanging and don't go
stuck put a couple of plants in there
she won't know uh don't wait better sex
is just a click away that's 50 off one
item free shipping with free Rush
processing just hey if you don't rushing
the process if you need to get it you
get it baby
just go to adamandeve.com select any one
item another code garbage at check out
that's garbage
g-a-r-b-a-g-e at adamandeve.com this is
an exclusive offer for our listeners be
sure to use code garbage to get your
discount 100 free shipping and Rush
processing that's adamandeve.com promo
code garbage Adam and Eve code garbage
gang but it's a gosh darn Family episode
we gotta get into some uh garbage
questions when you sign up for patreon
we will answer your garbage question uh
we get a lot of submissions like I've
said all the time but this is the best
way to do it everybody get page John
gets the first crack at it baby they're
the homies and we love them and we love
everybody but they get the first crack
the homies in the Bose
strong strong
I want to do like an army A Garbage
shirt but I feel with like
you know something here you don't get
somebody jammed up yeah exactly I don't
want someone to [__] end up on a
YouTube video but can I say this there
is a lot of those t-shirts now where
they're not military t-shirts but they
have like the flag on them and they're
tactical yeah tactical tactical t-shirts
yeah I don't know if they're contractors
or what the deal is but they're kind of
leaning into that yeah camo hats with
the sunglasses on top that was the only
thing about terminal list can I say that
that guy looked like a [__] Navy SEAL
he's trying to blend in he's got the
shades on top of the Hat he would have
got spotted a second ago he's walking
around with a rifle bag trying to blend
in what are we doing here you would have
picked them off immediately how do you
think he wasn't going to get caught at
that apartment complex
they were gonna know it was him
nothing I don't know what you're talking
about Toby knows exactly what I'm
talking about I do I just wanted to see
how long you would go I could go for a
walk
give me a water please
don't get me wrong I love Chris Pratt
it's a great show but come on fake beard
some sunglasses something plus everyone
around him's got to be trying to suck
his dick all the time he's the most
handsome man to ever live Chris proud of
the guy in the show Chris Pratt okay
yeah he's very Charming yeah shout out
to him I watch a lot of Parks and
Recreation [__] Star-Lord oh forget
about it he's all right Shelby the best
everybody's all right Matt yeah it's
good good program good program uh but
it's neither here nor there this is also
a good program that we have to get into
enough Dickie Dale and Dilly Dalian
Dicky Dalian or whatever user doing over
there that's what you're on [__]
Vicki dailies
sorry Kippy did six sticky dailies
don't do it man they're too hopped up on
Dickie Daley smoking Dicky dailies that
sounds like Ed medicine I tell you oh
that's we gotta take them daily I mean
Dicky Daley's
um all right this one's from Caleb's
Caleb Bliss uh first time long time
is it garbage if your school used to be
something else
my school used to be a Market Basket
supermarket and you can tell damn
that's [__] up what kind of cat can't
be like in elementary I can't be a high
school or something that's got to be
like a chi Institute that's real that's
got to be a private Endeavor that's real
small town [__] right there yeah because
you know the state builds the state or
the city or whatever the tax paying
dollars builds the public schools it
could be you know what got big in Philly
a lot of those Charter Schools yeah
where they just took over like
warehouses and [__] and factories I
always thought they were like good
schools but apparently they're not I
think they were and then they got not
good or something and they're always in
I don't know I don't know I know for I
know every now and then they get knocked
for something they get not for some
money some money scheme of like you know
it's like the principles doing the books
too there's no goddamn oversight you
know what I noticed
um
the opposite is not the opposite but not
schools that used to be something else
but schools that became something else
like what like uh I see a lot of uh
maybe South Korean churches in like
random ass buildings there's there's a
South Korean Church in my hometown that
used to be used to be like a school
it's real it kind of makes sense
religious school that all makes sense to
me a little bit yeah
I mean not I mean that seems more linear
than turning into a [__] you're going
to mass that's what I'm saying you're
going to mass in an old [__] Ground
Round
you know you just slapped across on
there the Lord's everywhere baby what do
you want from me he sees everything you
don't think he likes a nice Ground Round
Hey by the pay by the pound hey you're
not getting my money in the [__] in
the in the biscuit I'll tell you that uh
yeah that's that's all these uh
you always see that too especially like
in Philly like things that used to be
Wawas sure and there's still one in my
hometown that turned into like a flower
place I just got uh uh flowers there a
couple weeks ago for Mother's Day and
they're still booming Hoagies all right
too man they used to make a chicken parm
that would blow your [__] tits back
when they used to make it with a little
bit of love it was a chicken it was a
fried chicken tender breasts no all
right he used to have a breast not the
tender I like I remember when they had
the tenders they still do that's what
they that's what they make it with but
it was always like a fried chicken
breast like a you know a chicken patty
type thing but more of like a breast it
used to be
I'm not talking [__] all right but there
used to be more local Deli and I think
there's I think there's a lot of
um
confusion around the rest of the country
about the institution that is Wawa
there is a nostalgic thing it used to be
real tight it used to be very very mom
and pop sure you're not ordering on the
[__] board you know what I mean you
knew that you knew the meth head behind
the counter sure who made a hell of a
sandwich
you got to do at least a nickel to make
a decent Hoagie down here I remember
when they weren't method I remember when
it was just like neighborhood kids like
kids that my brother went to school it
was like you know like kids they were on
drugs stop it telling you I know it all
they were good people smoking weed at
least
whipped cream I was like I can start
today Jesus of course find the bullets
in the back let's go getting the Wawas
while you're dropping [__]
can we get more bread over here
yikes uh
uh you think I got drug problems um this
one's from Adam ten dollar homie never
had one red is it garbage to fly a
Jameson flag directly underneath the USA
flag on the pole in your front yard lawn
who
St Patty's Day I would let it slide if
you're Irish or anything yeah it's Gotta
Go American pow branch of the service
then you can do whatever you want but
what if you're not in those things and
you're something that you're in them you
just you know you're showing respect you
can't go [__] USA if you're not in
the service I don't think you can fly
pow Flags some guy a hammer drunk
cross-eyed folding the flag in his front
yard
he saluted
on behalf of a Grateful Nation
two dollar you call it if it touches the
ground you got to finish your drinks
uh no I don't know I don't know I don't
know if that's true
I don't know I don't know anything about
Flags but that doesn't seem that seems
like there's to me you have to there's
got to be a connection so when I see A
POW flag that means there was a pow in
that house or maybe it's a service
person I don't know T-Bone can you get a
look on that
um I thought that was just showing
respect
maybe I'm just coming from the other
angle where that seems like there's some
sort of connection sure I'm just saying
it'd be weird for me never served
something something to be like pows you
know what I mean there's a little bit
more emotional connection to that I
don't know it says they're either a
veteran or a Foley artist
that's a Foley artist the guys make
sound effects pal
they are veterans right I would assume
yeah yeah you would have to be that's
that's a little too uh
that's a little too deep of a cut yeah
so if you're not in the service or
anything or you're not you know you're
not waving the flag for something else
or some other thing and you like a nice
jamonique sure I don't care sure there's
a real trashy thing on the beach people
fly flags on the beach specifically in
Wildwood heavy bite I can imagine with
and those ain't always those those ain't
always pow Flags
yeah a lot of trump Flags that's the big
move these days a lot of let's go Larry
no it's not Larry let's go let's go
a lot of Curb Your Enthusiasm Flags LD
one more season baby that's how
unpolitical I am uh no what is it
let's go uh
Brandon
a lot of that kind of stuff gotcha
um we should when we do our we should
fly a flag on the beach Wawa flag that's
pretty good sure but then you got people
showing up looking like hey look he's
looking for a [__] classic
a bunch of people perusing my chip 86 to
quesadillas we're in the weeds
we're all working out of a tent now what
we should have is a [__] ayg flag
down there fly to goddamn colors what
are we doing
we're gonna [__] around get robbed down
there someone's gonna Google are you
garbage see the patreon and [__] hit
me over the head with a sock of nickels
they're gonna think I got that on me
come out of a way you got no pants on
yeah they've ruined through our [__] got
my wallet uh we should do some sort of
what do you do with your wallet down
there when you're if you're under not
with me with the whole family because
you got a bunch of goons down there I'm
talking when you're by yourself you put
the wallet in your sock or you put it in
your shoes
uh uh we typically have a I'm never at
the beach with just me and my wife I
feel and if I am I don't have my wallet
on me we'll take like a dub in case the
ice cream means walking by yeah
or I want to get a hot dog or something
by the way but I'm not rolling with
[__] plastic might have a connection
this summer down there to the fudgy
wedgie guys what do you mean might never
fam I can't can't speak too much on it
those are hard licenses to come still in
the works but
somebody I know
I might rob a fudgy wedgie guy no might
might start doing that that's a tough
[__] where at
uh
uh I want to say Ocean City maybe okay
could be wrong for the folks out there
that don't know what's the ice cream guy
down in Jersey Shore they push this
[__] cart around this metal box
around with huge tires in the burning
hot sun all summer selling uh fudge pops
Orange creamsicles
um dry ice they dry at first it takes
about 15 minutes where you can even
approach this thing that's how cold that
box is oh yeah you'll crack a [__]
tooth but that now Hot August Sun oh
about five minutes you're in heaven pay
that right now yeah but the original
this guy made the news the North
Wildwood fudge you wudgy man
retires after 50 years U.S Marine Corps
veteran known as Unk dunk
yeah talk about a reason and he would
hit you with banana
you hear him from about five blocks away
you come running out of the water those
frozen fruit paws are fantastic by the
way yeah the strawberry ones remember
them back in the day when those things
hit the scene good famous fudgy watching
man retires after 50 years saying
goodbye to North Wildwood you know what
that is that's a cash business right
there my friend sure but you got to be a
vet
at least in Wildwood you have to be a
vet and I know CI I think hot dog people
were firemen it's all it's all retired
service or first responder whatever
police or whatever maybe I'm getting
some bad information maybe you got a
bootleg fudgy wudgy guy selling fudgy
wedgies
Fiji wedgies step up and get your fidget
hey man this is root beer
is made in North Korea or something when
you were a kid did your mom ever pull
the move where she has like a treat
would give you the Frozen like daiquiri
mix out of the freezer that was in the
can you know what I'm talking about like
crack that open put in a bowl you put it
in like it was ice cream or sherbet man
you come from a [__] line of booze
bags
who the [__] just got strawberry
daiquiri mix laying around the house we
did as a kid I mean like I wasn't buying
it but yeah it was there that's from a
party or house a party sure but dude
that stuff was in
these they weren't entertaining that was
Fred that was after work that was after
work cocktails sure man if you're coming
home knocking down a [__] Frozen
[__] Daiquiri after work yikes I kept
on the lender going
you're plugging in appliances yeah
that's real Jimmy Buffett [__] right
there which ain't nothing wrong with it
nothing wrong with it I've said this
before but there was one July 4th uh in
you know can I say this you bust my
chops which rightfully so about what I
haven't never done anything of the sort
I haven't had a margarita in over a year
because I switched over to tequila and
sodas because they're so bad for you
it's all sugar and salt
just want to let you know an
accomplishment would be I stopped
drinking I switched to I still tequila
you just switched the vehicle sure okay
because that was your big thing when you
were losing weight was the margarita
dude we'd be in a [__] tji Saturdays
and you'd be like can I get an
all-natural Margarita I never I'll take
the Frozen
oh you don't have that no no [__]
[__] you guys don't you guys don't
muddle your own mint around here
all right I'll take them I'll take three
Frozen and two ipas please give it a
fire hose let's go
um are you talking about the cylinders
or like the frozen orange juice would
come in yeah totally they used to sell
strawberry [__] if I would have known
that yeah it was just straw but they
weren't there was no booze in them oh
yeah it was just strawberry juice or
whatever you know it was like water ice
because let me tell you something a
non-alcoholic strawberry daiquiri if
that ever was an option maybe once in a
blue moon Patty would let us get one of
those instead of a sodi man to a [__]
little fat kid
Fat Tuesdays
I had to show my tits to get the uh we
would get them on Vaca the few vacations
that we went on sure we went to Mexico
one time we do them there maybe if we
were at like you know what I take that
my pop used to have uh he would make uh
pina coladas he would make us
non-alcoholic Phoenix I think they were
non-alcoholic
I gotta hankering through [__]
Tequila Sunrise right now hey two more
Slippery Nipples for me and my pals I've
been trying to get us and go to sleep so
we can throw a move uh-huh um but every
once in a gray while he would break out
uh he would make his pina coladas and I
love them they break out the blender in
the ice but yeah that's trashy man
that's trashy but it's just water ice
really exactly yeah yeah uh I told you I
used to eat the frozen orange juice oh
yeah I was just talking to Patty about
that dude we drive her crazy she thinks
she's going in to get a nice thing of
[__] OJ put it in the warm water it's
just classic age Foley [__] bust my
balls for five minutes and then I used
to do the exact same thing yeah man I
used to do it even fatter
oh whipped cream in it be all right this
guy's [__] trash but that's not bad I
grew up doing that
I forgot about the Pina Coladas
it's good stuff I bet you did
you [__] whino okay let's talk about
Lucy Lucy goosey let's talk about
shaking up the nicotine routine whether
you're a nicotine gum guy are you like a
nice nicotine pouch Lucy has you covered
with fantastic flavors like apple ice
mango and even what's that espresso for
the aristocrats for after dinner uh they
let you choose your strength and flavor
it's fantastic uh Lucy pouches uh love
pouches but want your kick faster give
Lucy breaker pouches a try baby they got
it all they got you from A to Z baby
they're breaking it up shaking it up
shout out to Lucy for shaking up the
game these suckers contain these suckers
contain a liquid Crystal a liquid caps
hold on let me start that over these
suckers contain a liquid capsule to
moisten the pouch and get your nicotine
fixed faster straight to the source talk
about cutting out the middle man the HOV
lane let's go uh visit lucy.com
use promo code guard to get 20 off your
first order shipping is always free baby
that's Lucy l-u-c-y dot c-o promo code
garbage to receive 20 off and always
free shipping here comes the fine print
baby Lucy products are only for adults
of legal age every order is age verified
this product contains nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical
um got a [__] Lush over here
and then like a cocktail we did uh
who don't
we were we did it as July 4th they got a
five somebody came across a five gallon
jug up water ice and they put like two
handles of vodka in that yeah and that
it was a July 4th party on a dock
somewhere you could get him at Rita's I
think
no this wasn't Rita's this was like nah
I think Rita's only does the courts if
they put themselves out of business I
think if they started slanging the five
gallons true I don't know though true
but uh
yeah and that one I remember if I was 16
and my uncle who was a cop
at the time
was like is he how old are you I'm like
16 he's like he can have one I'm like
yes I can [__] everybody's mouths all
blue and [__]
it was blue raspberry all [__] up yeah
man the blueberry blue raspberry water
ice
take me back
out of my cold dead hands well we do all
right so back to the original thing we
do have to come up with a flag for our
beach trip a little a Little Acorn so if
anybody sees it don't know you come up
and dap us up okay
and a pack of cigs yeah something like
heaters.com or something like that yeah
two of my land fat guy by the sea
Paul Revere nothing
two of my land what if by Sea they
didn't teach you that at your [__]
hippie School up there it was it was in
Massachusetts for God's sake no it
wasn't it was oh that was in New
Hampshire idiot oh man you don't know
what I'm talking about we know nothing
about Toby
dude I constantly have to ask him what
his birthday it is
you don't know what two if by land one
if by Sea means sure don't wow man and
that's why
country's going to hell in a hand basket
that's the Youth of this country right
here I'm 33.
[Laughter]
okay
you know what it means right uh yeah
moving on uh but I would have to assume
two days by land one if you travel by
sea two off by land one of by sea why
are you yelling at me I don't know what
it means because you're flunking in
school that's why
embarrassing me
Paul Revere I know who said it I don't
know what it means I don't steal Valor
I don't give a [__] I know who said it
what's it mean he rang the bell twice if
they were coming by land and he'd ring
it once and they were coming by the Sea
it was the Brits I'm coming right now
yeah I know what it was in reference I
didn't know what it meant
he had no idea what I was talking about
no two of my land one if I see sounds
like you know two hot dogs if you're on
the land and one's on a boat yeah that
sounds like a surfinger sounds like a
surface Long John Silver's yeah that
ain't bad either I think that might have
been a surf and turf at Long John
Silver's give that a goog that might
have been a couple of the chicken strips
and maybe one of the haddocks
well shout out to Long John Silver's by
the way LGS I think we're just never
around
the first time I saw one I was [__]
24 probably I was living in South Philly
it was the first time like I would had
at like I would walk by one there was
one in Wilkes-Barre it was like Mecca
we'd go there get the hush puppies extra
Crunchies what's biting today
it's I'm not finding anything for any
appetizer sampler type deals but there
is a bar in the village one if I land
two if I see it looks like a real dive
[__] looks like our speed really
pretty good so in the in the Village of
New York City yes sir huh
there's a couple good fish and chip
places up there that ain't too shabby
where in the village
okay yeah they also do the deep fried
Snickers bars they're big in the same
place yeah they're bigger one in the
village where are we talking about the
village in the West Village or East
Village the white okay you said they're
also big in London they are big fish and
chips they're huge in London you do you
were just talking about snickers The
Village London and fish and chips I
didn't know what the [__] was going on
at the fish and chip places they do
fried Snickers they do fried Snickers
never heard of that yeah
there's one in the village oh it's
[__] you might you mind dropping us
for me you're not backing me up on that
either 100 that is uh in uh I believe
yeah in the UK is the only place I've
ever eaten a holy a full fried meal
fried slice of pizza uh whoa french
fries and a fried Oreo for dessert book
the tickets
we're going to London and isn't it I
don't care how you're coming whatever
you want bringing them fried Snickers
I don't like that the Oreos that does
all that stuff doesn't do it for me the
fried whatever like I get it I've tried
a bunch of it but it's like it's just
lost on me I'd rather just take a
[__] straight up snickies okay who
don't like his sneakies hungry why am I
gonna wait for it to be fried I'm hungry
now sure I'm not gonna wait
um this one's from Paul Simmons uh never
have one read tan cars question mark
yikes you're a tan car man you're a tan
car man I would argue I would even
extend it we are we were a tan car
family wow never my mom's bravado was
tan champagne I think they called it but
they started calling in that [__] in
the 90s yeah so when the ultimate
started hitting uh we had either way
you're not seeing your kids all right no
a tan car get the [__] 80. I had the
Montego was tan
uh
uh champagne I would call it the bravado
is tan my stepdad had a Suburban that
was tan
that's crazy man would you work for the
ATF a tan Suburban that's a rough
driveway
because that's when you pull up to Waco
in a tan Suburban
that's crazy huh yeah we can't really
talk too much [__] because uh oh I know
for a long time for a while my mom had a
[__] real nice gleaming white Maxima
Gina Russian mob who drives she's taking
numbers dude and I grew up in uh outside
Northeast Philly every every connected
Russian dude
sure going to Golden Gates and [__]
shout out to it they put a nice spread
down there uh yeah well white cars are
trashy white cars are trashy even I
think on like the higher end like a
Bentley or a Rolls-Royce what about a
white Mercedes they usually look pretty
nice that's yeah but that's still like
that's like hot mom [__] sure
or drug dealership okay remember when we
saw one the other day there was two
dudes in the we were talking we're like
is that guy a drug dealer or not yeah he
was like an associate some guy we knew
of outside circles and you're like is
that guy a drug dealer I'm like I'm
[__] up I'm pretty sure yeah and then
he got in a something we were like
that's a [__] drugstore car sure
um yeah but dude I never thought of that
10 cars 10 cars bad luck
Green's pretty bad too emerald green
Annie green if you think about it I mean
if you're going kelly green
that's crazy you better be on your way
to a Birds game but they don't I don't
think you can probably get green cars
anymore
no I thought maybe you don't see new
green cars listen whatever the [__] is
going on with these with these car
colors now they flattened them out they
are so [__] whack it looks it looks
like it was painted and painted in a
nursery room I got a nursery school like
the Broncos and stuff it's the flat it's
not shiny it doesn't have to it doesn't
have the glitter lame that's cool you go
navy blue you go black navy blue you
ever had a navy blue car
no that's trash silver Silver's good it
depends fire apple red
you're looking to shake that ass uh
Denise's Denise had a red Sebring
convertible like red red or burgundy
we were big on burgundy not burgundy
what's burgundy maroon same thing but it
was more more red than purple it wasn't
the purple color my dad had a [__]
red uh rocket no a red red Stinger on
them
he had a um
a red Mustang for a minute
I think you might have I bought it what
do you mean no I knew you when he had
that he had that
when I started comedy because I remember
I drove it to a show one time
well I never seen you drive until about
two years ago really you got in that bad
accident and then like oh yeah I got
that was in a bad accident
um he was like freaked out I never I
honestly didn't think he had a license
for the first decade that I knew you
[__] Jersey those goddamn jug handles
it was pouring rain I was on my way to a
50 show it was my first paid spot I
remember the guy whose shell it was yes
of course because he stiffed me on a
bill
not too long after that I thought my
career was over
because you got in a car accident and
missed the 50 yeah it was it was on
Halloween night well I got news for you
pal the last episode
Kippy says not a big ax a big accident
you say not a big accident so in my head
it's an 18 car pile up 23 fatalities
full-blown I just know he complained
about it for seven years you get the guy
tried to put the screws to us it was a
miscommunication at a red light you
stopped there you went
miscommunication at a red light
this guy trying to take us to the
cleaners
no I thought you said I would go uh yeah
I remember that really rattled you I was
living in your basement at the time no
you weren't yeah yes I was because I
remember when they called and said it
was all taken care of I was in your
basement
I didn't know you not when it happened
yeah when the litigation was going on
the jury was still deliberating on this
one
yeah you're right your honor because me
and my dad had to go out and these guys
a loser he's got
nothing man me and my dad had to drive
out to Jersey to go to to go to you're
reading the letter litigation like
partying
this shit's litigation bro
me and my dad had to go out and get uh
deposed is that what it is the last
show to the courthouse to throw in
[__] Lions no that's the first time
we went to a Bob Evans delicious [__]
place really do it right find a nice Bob
Evans good breakfast yeah yeah it's
tough to [__] up breakfast
um but
how do I get a smirch the man's name I'm
not I buy his sausages all the time I'm
[__] I I got it in a crib right now
Jimmy Dean's family Bob Evans get out of
here the Bob Evans patties yeah the
preacher Jimmy Dean crumbles come on man
knows his way around a pork product I'll
tell you that yeah but then what do you
put something for breakfast
I like that I like to I like the ground
sausage that seems indulgent to me why
that's real greasy I feel you can't dry
that you gotta run that through a
strainer dude that's real and that's
decadent that's like bone marrow you
can't dude that's why you're fat you
can't be eating that stuff at breakfast
you start getting the ground sausage
there's no real way to measure it either
you're really eyeballing it I know
because the only time I do it is I've
said this before is Thanksgiving Day
morning my mom makes the packets of that
for the sausage yes and me and my
brother always go after one and that's
like that's a ball I mean you're just
you got a ladle going yeah two it should
be two patties from Bob Evans who's a
gentleman who measures it out for you
you're raw dogging it but that's if you
get a sausage and cheese omelet it
should be ground it in a perfect world
it should be ground salt that I'll give
you yeah they don't do it
they don't do it who anybody
you gotta you gotta you get a sausage
and cheese omelet anywhere
it's never gonna be ground sausage it's
always going to be on the sausage um I
go bacon bacon and cheese on me sausage
on the side you do the wings you do the
patties whatever they got sure I'm a
sausage on a side guy okay
um but [__] what were we just saying
Bob Evans
breakfast
what do you got you cut me off
something Jimmy Dean Jimmy Dean sausages
got nothing
um all right let's see this is uh zap by
Brendan uh never had one red where are
you are you garbage if your parents made
the McDonald's parking lot the switch
spot for joint custody oh man that's bad
we used to you don't stand the chance
coming out of that
that's real tough especially if you
don't get they don't get you nothing
yes yeah if you're at a McDonald's not
eating oh man that's weirder for
something Dad we're gonna have pizza at
home we used to do this move
which was pretty trashy uh the
Pennsylvania Turnpike
if my parents were going somewhere
it was only a few times but if they
didn't want to pay the toll and we were
like going down to my cousins for a
weekend or something like that my
cousins lived right near it wasn't an
exit ramp it must have been like a
service entry like an access road or
something yes and it was a chain it was
a chain link fence for like a for like a
you know like a hundred yards and it was
a big gate that turned on to a regular
street so my parents would just pull
over on the turnpike and let us out and
we would sneak through the fence and my
my Uncle Mike would pick me up there and
take us to the house oh so they didn't
have to get off the turnpike and pay the
toll which was probably at the time then
they would just turn around at a rest
stop or something yeah which was no no
because once you get off you won't we no
no they were going they were like going
down the shore or something like that oh
I see what you're saying yeah because I
want to get off and back on they didn't
want to get off and back on the probably
75 cents I would have to assume yeah
dude I mean back in the day to get to
the from Philly to the shore it would
cost you about going down about six
bucks got one back it was about 11.
or something like that they were just
built different they just didn't want to
waste money or spend money or it was
weird so doing hot drops like sicario
yeah Jesus Christ
tuck and roll
if anybody looks at me I'm blasted
Josh Brolin picking me up
[Laughter]
man talk about a film that's one of my
faves one of the ones I want to go back
and I wish I could re-watch for the
first time when they throw down at the
border crossing God damn it he is cold
as [__] ice yeah it's all right it's
a good program a good film
um
damn yeah we
we used to have drop meat off points
when we would want to go hang out with
my
cousins that lived in Jersey what was
your situation that would you guys were
everybody was cool enough that your mom
would drop you off at your dad's your
dad would drop you off at your mom's
right a burden was 99 on my dad to get
me oh to come get you well like I would
go all my school might like I said
recently I would the bus would drop me
off at my mom's and I have to wait for
my dad to come get me oh inside they'll
let you inside my mom yeah yeah of
course well I don't know if it's his day
don't even look inside hey [__] his
brother it's my day you [__]
don't even hug him
I mean I can see where your mom would be
coming from you know what I mean well
she wasn't home she was working yeah but
you know what's in there is the goddamn
snack drawer and she don't need you on
her [__] off days you in their
[__] rifle and threw her goodies yeah
no that was the whole idea then he would
pick me up like I'm a little hungry
Mickey D's or Angelo's on the way out
shout out to gyross the CIA I like it uh
yeah so we had that we never really did
a switch but we would switch with my
aunt if like my aunt was going down the
shore or something yeah back when they
were all like really working like you
know
and I would have to that we would meet
at Franklin Mills Mall
and do us do a switch in the parking lot
holy [__] uh-huh would you guys change
license plates there
I have to do it in the parking garage so
we can pull out I had to switch cars
three times you got a bleach bomb and a
minivan
dumping a bunch of hair
for South Boston's DNA's in his car they
went into the parking garage at
Philadelphia Airport the car's still
there they're gone
cut two four eight-year-olds with
mustaches getting on a plane
hahaha
a bunch of captains outfits uh yeah
that's tough man that's a built
character it does man it it truly does
um all right let's see here uh anything
like that as a kid where you knew
something was something Patty had a
couple of moves like that I remember
like waiting in the car when she was
doing something nothing nefarious but
you know picking I don't know something
up yeah kids were just in the car I
don't think you can do that anymore no
kids were just it didn't matter
at some point I would assume in the
early two late 90s probably I guess it
was yeah like late elementary school or
whatever and I I was more of age I would
get the keys left for me yeah that was
big or if my brother's sister in the car
you know when I was like five they would
leave the keys but I mean like
uh for yeah we were just in fight over
the radio hanging yeah and for some
reason you thought you could never get
out of the car
you know what I mean now I'd get up have
a [__] eater go for a walk hit the
Rite Aid but like but you're out of that
car they come back and you're not there
oh you're [__] yeah Patty put the if
we got out of the car I was assumed that
there were kidnappers just waiting
around my blind spot they grabbed me
throw my fat ass in the van uh uh yeah I
remember one time my cousin
I don't know if we were picking him up
he was in high school I was probably
whatever they were probably damn my
brother and cousin shout out to Sean uh
was a list who's a listener he Johnny he
ran away or something from his you know
I'm running away I'm [__] he like
failed to test something you know some
blow up at home as a youngster ran away
my brother tried to pull that [__] I
think he was just staying
at my house or something I don't know
but he was it was when you could burn
burning CDs was big and he was burning
you know like mixes or whatever because
he probably stopped going to school for
like two days and he was kept making CDs
DJ runaway and he was like tat like DJ
runaway number one number two he's not
like dude this is a [__] good time
he's gonna launch his music career in
the basement DJ crashing at my cousins
ah I told you before we had a couple of
uh a couple separate occasions my
brother a couple of his boys stayed with
us something at home or whatever sure
yeah I remember Keith Cody staying with
us for [__] a couple of weeks one
spring coolest [__] kid ever it was
all right yeah double the t-shirts get
to take their t-shirts yeah for sure
good time I was always I mean I was 11
my brother's friends were in high school
or whatever I would be wearing their
clothes like things they left or
something he would come home with like a
cool pair of cargos I mean there was a
camo pair of cargo shorts that fit me
perfect you couldn't tell me [__] dude I
I rolled up the [__] I rolled up this
meet the boys skating they were like
whoa you can't even see his dick worn in
perfectly yeah oh yeah it was great get
a nice T-shirt with a little rip right
here yeah looks like [__] mites got
at it or whatever
but we gotta wrap it up gang gang we
love you tell you this right now the
bald kid ain't lying we love you to
death sure do us a favor come out and
see us on the road there again August
11th we added a second show uh-huh over
there at the Vogel theater in Red Bank
New Jersey it's gonna go so grab some
ticks bring the squad and come out and
hang with the boys check out are you
garbage.com and we will see you next
week